you know it's wonderful isn't it I'm so
glad that we were in London for as well
hi in town is very it's a very
bittersweet kind of thing you know it's
amazing to think that some of these kids
here weren't even born when we did
Lawrence you know when we were
premiering that all the rings and and
the fact that like you know they're out
and we're loving this and that you know
you feel like you've been a part of
movie history in a way I know and that's
that's a really special thing for me
well I think it's gonna be you know I
mean honestly this this movie's got it
all
you know I think I think that the
experiences it's the last piece in the
puzzle of a very long journey so it
connects the Lord of the Rings to the
Hobbit and it's the end of this journey
cells fantastic you know I think Peter
Jackson to be honest Peter Jackson was
the was the driving force behind the
movies you know you know New Zealand's
landscape was his and was is fantastic
for shooting in or something like this
but you know he's grown up and lived
there and knows it so well that he kind
of knew every nook and cranny to in
which in order to make a great film
there writing isn't it I mean it comes
from you know these great novels by you
know JR Tolkien really and then you know
they you know they really they really
Pete really and embraced a story and the
world and you know he's really the
authority on that world and he he didn't
he always honored it you know he honored
the stories and I think that the fans
respect and appreciate that
you